on this episode I talk about acting
human in an automated world I talk about
East Coast versus West Coast and I talk
about being over here while you're over
there you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show you're
watching episode 31 of the askgaryvee
show as you know and 31 little fun fact
on that number that is the newest number
in my roulette gambling career because
Misha
that's right Misha my lovely daughter
was born with 31st that got added to
rotation Zander Broughton born in the
17th he's my youngest but my grandma
already had that number so no new number
because of Zander before we get into the
questions this week I want to obviously
talk about the new thing you might have
noticed me mentioning it in the intro I
am now doing an audio podcast which is
up on iTunes there's also a link right
here and there's an RSS feed in that
page on garyvaynerchuk.com
for all you Android users and we're
gonna be on stitcher and you know all
this other stuff probably this week
Google Play this week really enjoying it
little fun fact for all of you that are
listening right now episode 29 and 30 of
last week I was in San Francisco the
audio quality wasn't great so we decided
to take it out of the rotation of the
audio you're getting this one so you'll
see a little skip there also episode 5
had that iconic issue so you don't see
that in the rotation for all you video
peeps now you have the ability to take
me on the go when you're running or in
the car if you're not sitting down and
watching super excited about the podcast
please sign up you see what I'm doing
Dirac sign up enjoy it pass it on lots
of people in the podcast world enjoying
that kind of stuff I'm excited to be a
part of it Mauricio asks I'm a
self-taught social media marketer is it
worth doing a course on when I'm
applying for jobs there's you know you
know it's an interesting question uh I'm
self-taught I didn't take any courses in
social media I think it's done OK for me
but in general I'm not a good student
either and I don't I never took a real
substantial course in business or
marketing either and that's worked out
alright for me I think this is an answer
that really matters based on being
for where I think if you find yourself
as somebody who you know in general
being a self-taught social media expert
in general I'm cynical to that I think
99% of you are clowns and are just
reading headlines and are not
practitioners and don't go deep I'm even
scared of you taking a course because
most of the courses I've seen when I've
come and spoke at that class when I
vetted the teacher through the them
interviewing me process I've realized
they were clowns and so in a whole ring
Lee brothers and Bonham berry circus
kind of environment it all scares me I
would tell you the thing that most
matters to me is to become the most
surgical deepest knowledgeable
practitioner you can be but I can't
really answer this for you there's too
many variables one are the courses good
- are you the type that actually can
learn in that environment I can't on the
flip side by being a practitioner that's
the best way I learn and so that's a
whole lot of ego and bravado and I
apologize for all my listeners on iTunes
that aren't used to this but I'm just
spitting the truth social media right
now is in a very awkward early stage if
you go back and look at the early
internet marketers of 1995 six seven
eight nine
they were spewing a lot of crap as well
and so it's a difficult timing I would
say this in five years I feel a lot more
comfortable you taking that course chase
asks on an average day how many
impressions do your tweets get chase oh
it's gonna say I chase stick there Steve
Chase this man has done the work give
him the credit given the airtime Steve
what is it what is the answer so his
28-day average is 240,000 impressions
per day and that's six point seven
million over the last 28 days there you
go that is the answer and let's give you
a better answer to everybody overall
because I'm not sure what that means or
if we care the more important question
is how many of those impressions cared
what I can tell you is in 2011 when I
had a hundred thousand followers on
Twitter I was getting more engagement
more interaction selling more books
getting more people to watch my videos
because of it and this speaks to the
thing that I most care about in the
world the supply and demand of a
nothing else matters going to platforms
early on when there's early tribes there
and they're paying more attention that
is to me the upside of jumping into
snapchat early the upside of jumping
into new platforms like vine early you
look at the first people that over
indexed it on vine they are massively
internet famous right now on YouTube and
snapchat and Instagram and other places
along with vine and the ones that are
popping now on vine are not getting to
that same level so the impressions the
reach it matters but the depth is what
matters the most and more importantly
the attention of that consumer on that
platform when something's new it's a
little more sticky when a new song comes
out you listen to it a bunch of times
and then it gets into rotation Twitter
right now is in rotation in a social
media world versus where it was four or
five years ago and so though my top line
followers are more it's my depth that I
worry about and that is a thesis and a
strategy that all of you need to figure
out across the board Robert asks back in
the old school days of hip-hop were you
East Coast West Coast or both Robert
biggie changed my life some East Coast
but I will tell you something I'm
throwing you for a real curveball
especially because it's good times in
Cleveland right now I'm a little bit
more Cleveland I was all in I mean like
let's put all the pieces in here I was
all-in on Bone Thugs and harmony take me
to the crossroads every time East 99 is
where you'll find me uh so I'm a little
bit more Cleveland
hey Gary it's Jason Calacanis I love the
new show and just a question for you
short or long videos I like long ones
you do short ones who's right in the
situation what's the value of short
versus long videos explain great
question at Jason fun to see some of the
internet famous peeps showing up on the
show uh you know it's funny I hear him
say I like long ones you like short ones
why not be TV was 30 minutes every day
so I've been in the long game unless
he's talking an hour which is fine but
like now we're getting into nitpicking
uh I like both and and here's what I
would say avatar three plus hour
people Sat listen to it loved it a
tremendous Jerome Jarre my partner in
grape story six-second vine video people
loved it
sit through it I actually think Jason
and vaynernation uh that length has no
variable on quality you need to play
within your length but you can watch an
hour and 40 minute movie and think it
sucks right or you can watch a
six-second vine and think it sucks to
counter my earlier point of those
quality outputs within those time
lengths and so to me which one's better
both uh you know cuz I'm a positive guy
somebody would say neither uh and uh and
I think it comes down to what are you
doing within those constraints and I
think it becomes contextual the skill it
takes to make a three-hour feature film
is very different than a skill it takes
to make a six-second vine video or
15-second Instagram video to capture
somebody's attention and so that's my
answer
George asks what's your take on
marketing automation software George the
key here is you know I'm not a huge fan
of automation I've talked that up about
that at nause as a matter of fact once
and for all
because I keeps coming up and I know a
lot of people are now new listeners on
iTunes if you ever get a tweet for me or
apply to youtube comment or reply in the
facebook comments like I did all weekend
it is me there is no outsourcing of my
engagement I had to make a video to
prove it this weekend I don't you guys
saw that like to prove that it was me
tweeting it is me the way to humanize
automation for people that want to send
out things is the follow-up so if you
put something out and you schedule it
not my style
I'm against that because here's what's
dangerous about automation especially in
social and email for all the people I
had a lot of friends that I killed them
on this let's go back to a very sad day
the Boston Marathon mascar right after
that happened over the next hour to the
amount of people that tweeted
promotional buy my book check out my
show sign up for my course my friends I
was emailing and DMing them and saying
you
we're ruining your brand you are there
are 40 people right now that will never
respect you again because of what you're
doing and so in a world where everything
is real-time scheduling is dangerous for
those anomaly moments where you can look
really bad and don't let mainstream
media pick you up that you're promoting
your book after the president's been
shot or a building's been exploded or a
terrorist act happened because that can
be the end of your career completely to
me that is not worth the upside of the
automation but if you go the automation
route fine here's how you make it human
you act human behind it you put
something out people are engaging with
it you come in humanely and engage it
this will be always a debate that I'm in
a minority which is I want to scale the
unscalable in a world where people are
trying to use modern technology to scale
it's as simple as that
I'm countercultural I'm over here you're
all over here you're all over here I'm
over here and I will stay here because I
believe in it and I believe in it not
because I'm romantic or Zen or or such a
great guy I believe in it because I
think it's sell [ __ ] you've been
watching episode 31 of the askgaryvee
show here is the question of the day
two-parter one and it's for the YouTube
comments than anywhere else one are you
going to sign up for the podcast yes no
it's quite simple don't let it get
complicated number two for all you
iTunes people that are listening right
now or sketcher or anybody who's
listening on the RSS jump in to my
YouTube channel and answer this question
for me what can I do to make this a
tremendous audio podcast for you you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering that crap wait subscribe I
need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in social so
subscribe